[Musique]
il faut faire de la vie est un rêve et
d'un rêve une réalité
alors moi mon rêve de petite fille c'est
être piloté des avions donc eh bien
aujourd'hui ce rêve est devenu mon
quotidien puisque depuis onze ans je
pilote des a320 et j'avais pas du tout
reste à faire par contre mais bon
parfois il ya des causes qui nous
dépasse réaliser ses rêves
c'est vraiment merveilleux
malheureusement tout le monde n'a pas la
possibilité de faire deux par les
embûches cruel que la vie met parfois
sur leur chemin telles que la maladie
lorsqu'il s'agit de la maladie d'un
enfant
ben c'est encore plus cruel et surtout
injuste il ya huit ans j'ai rencontré
une dame qui a bouleversé ma vie
elle avait créé une association pour
réaliser des rêves d'enfants malades et
handicapés cette association avait créé
en mémoire de son fils et elle
souhaitait du coup aider des familles au
destin semblable au sien
alors j'ai été bien sûr ont touché par
la cause ému et puis je me suis senti
très égoïste et donc j'ai eu envie de
les aider parce que la question que je
me suis posée c'est toi que fais tu pour
les autres donc j'ai commencé à vendre
des petites peluches bénéfices de cette
association alors je dépends des eaux
collègues et qui je partais en vol parce
que comme ça enfermé avec moi dans
l'avion il n'avait pas tellement
d'autres choix lassé de m'écouter et du
coup éventuellement acheter une peluche
ça a tellement bien marché que on m'a
surnommé la pilote des nounours en
peluche après peluche
excusez moi j'ai du coup j'ai appuyé
sans faire exprès peluche après peluche
je me suis investi un petit peu plus
comme en salle à l'hôpital et j'ai
réalisé le premier rêve d'enfant il ya
deux ans et demi elle nous a un petit
peu encouragés à créer une association
pour continuer son combat est donc avec
mes proches nous avons fondé association
fait des rêves
notre but donc soutenir des enfants
gravement malades ou lourdement
handicapées quel que soit leur
pathologie
il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont touchés
par ce que parce que nous faisons au
quotidien
mais parfois la question que l'on peut
se poser c'est à quoi ça sert réellement
quel est l'impact sur la maladie de la
réalisation d'un rêve
en théorie on pourrait s'imaginer qu'il
s'agit juste d'un petit peu de bien-être
un moment fugace d'échappatoire dans la
maladie dans la réalité est bien plus
incroyable que ça réaliser le rêve d'un
enfant malade
c'est jesse est bien plus qu'un simple
don c'est un geste il ya des
répercussions importantes sur la vie
d'un enfant sur sa famille et sur le
système de soins il ya une association
canadienne comme la nôtre qui a mené une
étude en ce sens quatre impacts majeurs
en sont ressortis et les résultats sont
très impressionnants
le premier impact c'est l'impact
émotionnel faut savoir qu'il est
important de vivre des moments de
bonheur en cette période difficile comme
ça me bouleverse vous parler par exemple
de la maman de kevin qui nous a appelés
au secours ya quelques jours pour que
l'on réalise le rêve de son fils ce
qu'elle nous a dit c'est qu'il a besoin
d'un moment de bonheur parce
qu'aujourd'hui ça fait 14 ans qu'il se
bat contre les traitements
il n'en peut plus et ne les supporte
plus réaliser le rêve d'un enfant malade
c'est le rendre heureux
pour la première fois depuis souvent
bien longtemps ce qui est ressorti dans
l'étude dès qu'on voit sur le graphique
c'est qu'en fait ça augmente le niveau
de bonheur et d'espoir perçue par
l'enfant un enfant malade dans une
famille c'est un séisme qui touche tout
le monde
les parents les enfants il ya des
problèmes annexes qui viennent se
rajouter parce que comme si la maladie
ne suffisait pas des problèmes
financiers par exemple quand un des
parents de mettre sa carrière de côté
pour accompagner son enfant à l'hôpital
le fait aussi de leur permettre de
réaliser le rêve ensemble en famille ça
leur permet de resserrer les liens
familiaux de mieux composer avec la
maladie est tout bêtement d'avoir un
sujet de conversation pendant les soins
parce que qu'ils soutiendront quotidien
c'est sa famille donc son bien-être
un réel impact sur le moral de l'enfant
le deuxième impact c'est l'impact de la
distraction
donc non seulement ça leur permet de
moins penser au traitement et à la
maladie mais en plus de nombreuses
études ont déjà montré que quand l'on
rit la distraction inhibe
les signaux de douleur est reçue par le
corps c'est pour ça que nous avons
choisi d'offrir au quotidien plusieurs
animations dans différents services
hospitaliers il régulièrement le
personnel de soins ne fait pas des
effets bénéfiques qu'ils observent sur
les enfants est derrière sur le
déroulement de leur traitement pour vous
donner un exemple il ya trois ans on a
mis en place une animation musicale au
sixième étage de l'hôpital de la timone
à marseille dans ce service
il ya un petit garçon qui doit porter en
continu une assistance respiratoire
sauf que cette assistance respiratoire
il ne la supporte pas
et depuis que le musicien vient il a dit
allez du katri du service qu'il arrive à
mieux l'accepter
ça c'est génial
c'est l'impact physique donc non
seulement le fait de réaliser leurs
rêves ou d'avoir des animations leur
permet de moins penser au traitement de
mieux vivre la maladie et de mieux
supporter le quotidien à l'hôpital mais
en plus ça redonne une énergie aux
enfants et le système immunitaire
on a besoin d'une sacrée dose en fait
pour se battre au quotidien contre la
maladie et l'appareil
on l'a observé à travers les rêves que
l'on a réalisé notamment il ya un an et
demi il ya une infirmière de l'hôpital
de montpellier qui nous a appelés
elle voulait que l'on réalise le rêve de
ta part
il rêvait de rencontrer les acteurs
d'hélène et les garçons et oui alors il
fallait faire vite parce que parce que
malheureusement les jours de ta étaient
comptés et lorsque les les acteurs se
sont déplacés sa maman nous a appelés
donc voilà tard avec les acteurs elle
nous a appelés elle pleurait de juin et
ce qu'elle nous a dit c'est ce
extraordinaire
merci merci parce que tu as été couché
depuis trois semaines il ne pouvais plus
lever aujourd'hui s'est levé il a marché
et danser et après ce moment de bonheur
il s'est accroché à la vie pendant plus
d'un an alors que c'était inespéré
le quatrième impact c'est un impact
durable
donc non seulement ils vivent un moment
de bonheur intense sur le coup mais en
plus les effets sont bénéfiques sur le
long terme parce qu'en fait il ya des
souvenirs heureux qui arrive alors que
la période est particulièrement
difficile elle a aussi excuser moi alors
donc le dernière dernière passe donc
l'effet durable
donc il ya huit ans quand j'ai commencé
à réaliser les rêves d'enfants
le tout premier rêve que j'ai réalisé
c'était celui de jean baptiste jean
mathis ils avaient mon âge il était
hospitalisé à l'hôpital de san salvadore
hier ils étaient atteintes ce qu'on
appelle le locked in syndrome alors je
ne sais pas si je ne sais pas ce que
c'est
il était complètement emmuré dans son
propre corps et il ne pouvait plus que
cligner des yeux
alors ils communiquer comme ça c'est
extrêmement difficile à vivre et donc il
était passionné de littérature il avait
écrit un recueil de poèmes en clignant
des yeux il avait été primé édité et
donc à la sortie de son recueil les
infirmières de l'hôpital de san
salvadour ont eu envie de lui faire
plaisir
et donc on organiser une signature de
recueil comme les grands auteurs et donc
elles ont fait organiser ça hier à la
médiathèque de hyères et donc elles nous
ont demandé de contacter grand corps
malade parce qu'il est fan de grand
corps malade
grand corps malade est venu ça a été un
moment extraordinaire et ce moment a été
filmée médiatisé et donc en fait jean
baptiste a regardé la vidéo de ce moment
tous les jours bien dernier un pacte
alors celui là il est il est pas dans
l'étude en fait c'est l'impact que cela
a sur les bénévoles des associations
alors là je vais parler pour moi parce
que pour le coup j'ai de quoi je parle
en fait quand j'ai commencé à réaliser
des rêves d'enfants malades quand j'ai
commencé à m'investir dans cette
association
je les fais parce que j'avais envie de
rendre un petit peu du bonheur que la
vie m'offre tous les jours et et que je
pensais que c'était utile mais en fait
je n'avais pas du tout imaginez l'effet
que ça aurait sur ma propre vie j'avais
absolument pas imaginer à quel point ça
me rendrait heureuse d'aider les autres
je n'avais pas imaginé toutes les
émotions que j'allais ressentir tous les
liens amicaux qu'ils allaient se
resserrer parce que du coup cette
association c'est un groupe d'amis voilà
est en fait j'avais pas imaginer que le
prince allait bouleverser ma vie tout
simplement
donc j'en profite du coup aussi pour
remercier tous les gens qui nous aident
qui nous permettent de rendre cela
possible parce que évidemment il ya des
moments où on se met la pression
comme maintenant par exemple
et il ya des moments où tu mets la
pression parce qu'évidemment il faut
récolter les fonds nécessaires pour
pouvoir financer tout ça il faut arriver
à contacter les artistes et parce qu'on
n'a jamais envie de décevoir les gens
qui qui place de l'espoir en nous y
voilà et du coup pour conclure
j'aimerais simplement vous vous inviter
à partager de rêve avec moi le premier
ce serait d'imaginer que tout le monde
puisse un jour s'investir dans une
association dans une une activité
caritative ou humanitaire
une heure par mois par an 1 euro mais
imaginez le nombre de vies qui
pourraient être impactées et améliorer
et le deuxième rêve ce serait d'imaginer
que la solidarité que l'amour de son
prochain
deviendrait une valeur fondamentale que
l'on transmettrait à nos enfants nous
pourrions nous pas rendre ce monde un
tout petit peu meilleure et si l'on
invité nos enfants à participer avec
nous à la réalisation des rêves
nous pourrions nous pas leur apprendre
que donner c'est mieux que prendre que
guérir c'est mieux que blessés etc et d
c'est mieux que combattre je remercie
maman
[Applaudissements]